tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo cazzo
bella tanti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo un nuovo
videogioco colloqui lustri allora prima
di cominciare ci avete presente tipo
subway serve quel gioco dove con
l'iphone
devi schiva ecco mosso cazzi nostri
l'effetto ragazzi tanto siamo si sono
sono morto ragazzi sono già persone un
po tutto da morto cioè sono un fenomeno
del gioco porta a trovare semplicemente
ragazzi sono solo john feroce che vado
mica a spostarmi vero nome è un
partigiano
allora siete stronzi però non riesco a
fare un [ __ ] m tra l'altro ragazze di
merda o dei migliori con me che devo
devo spostarmi perché sono non faccio un
metro
d'altro canto la prima interna è un
gioco tipo segway serva tipo quello per
iphone
io l'ho visto in faccia ragazzi non sto
capi un cazzo fermi un attimo si era
capito che tanto sbattevo da qualche
parte con l'onlus rift ragazzi era una
cosa stranissima ed altro
anch'io sono sono un pelato non mi
rispecchia praticamente porca [ __ ] che
facciata alla cam in attimo jerry e
riprovo perché allora devo prendere le
monete che fin qua ci sia la devo ok ma
io non ho capito
di certo abbassiamo c pure in una trave
alta un metro ci siamo ragazzi ho capito
come si gioca minimo non ce n'è per
nessuno
dalla prossima però che ci sia sì se
questa è quella buona
ma batte il record del mondo tanto ma
[ __ ] riusciva fatto il cazzo di m
a che non è possibile ci siamo mi chiara
ok ci sto prendendo gusto dalla
prefettura si stronzi a chi sono io
vorrei capire non ho capito i soldi se
passa della gente a caso va bene double
jungle non funziona io vorrei capire
perchè c'è della gente ha chiesto che mi
passa da wagner è possibile se neve con
altri fico una testata manco fosse
l'ultima cosa che faccio devo fare
fatelo battere io non ho capito perché
sono partito morto ed è c'era già il
record a caso c'è il ne poteva più che
ragazzi appalti apple tv i capelli
bellissimi sono un figo suo gas incamerò
buffa tutto devo ricordarmi di prendere
le monete perché sennò non prendo il
gelato lo sviluppo visto gioco
mediamente sarebbe arrivare il più
avanti possibile prima che prima di
sbattere come un minchione ragazzi
qualcuno mi deve spiegare perché sono
partito morto testa cosa non ha senso
però va beh non lo puoi più fare tutto
grazie
dopo tutto quanto hanno capito bene il
senso però veniva interni volta che ogni
volta che vedo un cazzo di carta non è
mica go in mano perché sembra che mi
arrivi in faccia davvero sul calcio
fatta certo che i ragazzi col mondiale
me ne frega niente
visto l a caso caso legame minchia cosa
che sono superman
[Musica]
vi sono spuntate le ali a caso va bene
ecco forse ho perso di quella moda
basta basta del dalle segnati il record
di ad arrivare a 1000 e tutto gasato ok
ma stavolta stavolta ci siamo non frega
niente
le monete ci hanno un occhio all'occhio
plus l'hanno visto questo hanno guardato
davanti [ __ ] devo arrivare ammiro
ragazzi non ci arriverò mai a mille
proviamoci perché non si sa mai allora
io devo capire perché ci sono degli
scheletri che mi arrivano in faccia
questa cosa ma ancora ma basta ma che
cazzo sarà tipo un concerto per
scheletri dopo l'affare non è prossima
con tutti ma che roba svolta al prossimo
che passa glielo chiedo che casa vai a
fare dietro tutto questo ragazzo non ha
un senso ma ma neanche am orientato agli
di pipistrelli ministro no questo non
l'ho visto da dove dove per il potere
della pelata
se io se io se là davanti con la pedata
minetto tra far ridere perché la
cambiamo c un attimo che ok ok andate
poi a concerto e non ci vado ragazzo
perfetto 400 siamo a metà quel che meno
a metà strada
taci sua area da ragazzi e e straziata
io guardo tutto ragazzi vederlo in prima
persona un gioco così è na figata
passata qualche fatto che tipo vento gli
ostacoli che mi arrivano in faccia
quindi tipo domani ci avrò mal di testa
di sicuro solo che non ho capito che zio
bobby fammi capire dove cazzo fatto ma
tu che cazzo stai andarmi mica l'ho
vista bruttissima la propria brutta
calmiamoci perché ti possono sono vivo
per miracolo ma veramente miracolo
assurdo adesso posso saltare due volte
perfetto mix zone a lire gasol e
all'altra perché c'è da paul jump non ho
capi come si fa saltare due volte con un
tempo una specie di carretto è
impossibile armi eccolo eccolo ce la
possiamo fare se si picchia goso
schivato 800 ragazzi
no non ci che non ci voglio credere
ghazi 800 800 lavorando dopo il sì sì sì
mi chiama sto facendo ragazzi
ammazzarsi la famiglia e tutti i tuoi
fratelli
vabbè sentite 913 ma vaffan corsi non ci
arriverò mai più ciechi e botta data la
domani cioè i lividi a ghiaccio i lividi
sul ginocchio ma studiando delle botte
pazzesca
ok luca su ok ragazzi contro i
pipistrelli proprio contro stop and
double giaquinto 326 ok no no ma come si
fa a entrare dentro un sasso come cazzo
fai li prenderebbe per un mongoloide ne
so niente io entro nei sassi
ho trovato ragazzi forse un modo trovato
per vincere ha trovato una sfera del
drago che sarebbe tipo questa ragazza
aveva una sfera del drago nascosta sotto
i capelli e non lo sapevo io ti invoco
drago share
non so neanche contare che abbassarvi
avete pazienza si si no
[ __ ] mai così mai così sente già
800 finché non arrivò a mille io da sto
gioco non stacco perché mi mi girano
troppi [ __ ] me lo dico no no no sì
sì bella ragazzi affacciarmi mi sento
tipo quando tentò di sfuggire
all'interrogazione frutti fosse cose a
caso si centro che mi devo anche girare
per vedere quanto sono perché se no non
lo so
ottocento si penso caccia mi piacciono
l'adrenalina a mille ragazzi
l'adrenalina a mille chimiche primi del
900 ragazzi si gioca tutto ma dio santo
ce l'ho fatta ho fatto mi odiano ragazzi
solo ansia non ci posso credere non ci
credo non ci credo non ci crederò mai
tivoli hanno adesso arriva a 4 milioni
le cacce non c'è video non arriva
neanche a mille adesso arriva a 12 mila
tipo che non si crei ma non ci posso
credere
cosa stessa schivando ma dio mio no
sì no no no no mi odio 1627 a caso
ragazzi matrix matrix non arriva una kia
mille sono arrivato a 1.626 stragà yo yo
yo con concludo qua record del mondo o
te sei casi niente va bene così e staff
ragazzi a quanto tragico se devo essere
sincero e spende anche nel successo stop
da dove sta passando sto caldo non
voglio più vedere un gioco così per il
resto la mia è stato orribile vi giuro
che comunque ragazzi spero che video vi
sia piaciuto che possono chiudere qui
come al solito ragazzi servito vi è
piaciuto lascia documento mi piace anche
la pagina di facebook e come non divida
tra tana descrizione presidi tecnici
diventiamo le professioni e noi ci
rivediamo ma che cazzo ciao giusto
telecomando ad un prossimo ad un
prossimo video bella ragazzi tacito